this is the spreadsheet we constructed
we saw how you could take you know hours
you can get the spreadsheet to add it
all up for you okay
and then you can work out based on
however much you're earning per hour how
much you're going to end with at the end
of the week so that's kind of cool and
our extension from that was this
we're looking at interest okay and we
saw how you could build
this guy
this awkward looking thing right which
some of you missed it
that is the compound interest formula
you might recognize it right let me
write it out again
this is our compound interest
formula and you can almost recognize the
pieces right
this blue one that's the principle
one plus there's the interest rate it's
written as a decimal because you've got
3.64 percent i think is what we looked
up from cba and then this green thing
what's the green thing represent
that's the time right yeah good the
power is how we have that hat right that
symbol says to the power of and a3 is
well that's the time okay so you can
recognize that's what we looked at
yesterday okay
now this scenario was all about getting
money and then seeing how it would grow
okay um over time if you just sat in a
bank account and didn't do anything okay
i want to extend that idea and look at a
bit of the negative side of what happens
when you have money and lots of it okay
so come back to this spreadsheet this
shake here
and this is one week right
but i would assume you work more than
one week a year okay so underneath here
let's put in here weeks
worked
okay so
how many weeks are there in a year
there are 52 okay now
probably an equally reasonable
assumption is that you don't work all of
those weeks okay does anyone know what's
the entitlement for if you're a
full-time worker what's the entitlement
for annually does anyone know
how much time are you allowed to take
off like say to go on holiday or like bc
all that kind of stuff
it's about a month it's four weeks
that's the australian
um
allocation for annual
you might want to um
you might want to actually note that
down because if you think about it right
this is a very very small amount of time
which is why if you know anyone if
you've got siblings or anything like
that who start full-time work it's
traumatic going to this right nathan um
isn't it in america like two weeks yeah
i think it's it's not much in the in the
award
how many holidays how many weeks of
holidays you have now
how many holidays how many weeks of
holidays um i think it's 12 because
you've got you've got your 52 weeks in
each year and then you subtract four
terms that are 10 weeks each right
approximately so you minus 40. that's 12
weeks okay so that's three times as much
holidays you're gonna get as a full-time
workout
you think that's right who's got
siblings in uni anyone yeah how many
weeks of holiday do they have do you
know
they get a lot you're like you're still
sitting around doing nothing right now
i'll tell you how to calculate it um
there are 52 weeks in a year right
and you should subtract and we have four
terms
of 10 weeks right now i know in uni you
don't get terms you get
semesters right there are two of them
how many weeks in a semester usually
it's not quite as luxurious today it's
13. okay so that means two semesters is
26 weeks of university classes which
means how many weeks if that's class how
many weeks of holidays do you get
26. so you thought you had it good
no wonder your
uni attending siblings look like they're
sitting around doing nothing though
hopefully they're actually going to do
some work okay
so anyhow
let's just go into this scenario so this
is your full-time workout full-time okay
so instead of 52 weeks i'm gonna put in
48 i think that's pretty normal yeah
yes
four weeks off for the whole year okay
now i'll admit that doesn't include sick
leave but that's like you can't just
take off sick leave you have to be
actually sick so if you want to go on a
holiday you want to take a trip or you
just want to stop working for a little
while
yeah that's all you get though for what
it's worth you can't accrue that so you
can wait like three years and you can
have 12 weeks backed up
you could do likely for that pay or you
could do
so there's there's annual leave there's
sick there's live without pay there's
long service leave if you've been
working at a place for like 10 years
okay but anyhow you get the picture
generally yeah last question
okay so
so school teachers we have this but
actually we're employed during your
school holidays which is why i do a
crapload of work when you guys
amy jacob
right now
all right leave your stuff here
quickly so you can come back soon
um so tom just on your question
christina questions
um you know how summer holidays is but
basically like five six weeks actually
so
the department of education the
government is a side note they assume we
get the same four weeks as everyone else
and they they lump it all into summer
right so those two week breaks two week
breaks two weeks breaks i'm still just
as employed as i as i normally am so and
i i am like i work pretty much
holidays
yeah well that's
yeah maybe he should be anyhow okay
so i'm gonna come back here i'm going to
change this to 48 okay
so now if that's the amount of weeks we
work and total pay up here that's how
much you're earning per week right
then if i want to work out your total
income
total income how am i going to work that
out
okay so i'm going to take that number
right whatever number is in there
and i'm going to pay how do i multiply
again um yeah use the
yes very good well done it would have
been easier if you're paying attention
the first time okay multiplication
times how much you're actually earning
per week okay so far so good
now what's happened do you remember what
this means
it's not big enough good very good okay
so i'll just double tap up here and
there's the amount of money i earn
that's not bad then again we did work a
lot for it okay